are there any impressions you um well
yes I do a pretty good Britney Spears
mind I think I did again
I made you been me lemon and just friend
oh baby yeah my esteem makkac rush
laughter than me I'm theory i'm 5-8 okay
yes and i add a nice shadow and
everything and i forgot it
can you actually do other impressions um
you know I do a pretty good Shakira
nothing hot stars give us yes any yeah I
just give us anything you guys I guess
it's very the role yes
can't you see I'm Alfie whatever
I meant to be together I'll be there and
you'll be near and not steal my dear
okay okay I was here cap so my cat well
here's let's play here's um I'm hungry
now
and here's don't touch my mouse toy I
have my cat and they both speak the same
languages they do we talk all the time
awesome okay uh ready for this thing
yes all right so cool
been a rough day hasn't it yes now
you're gonna tell me your dirty little
secret aren't you yes a dirty little
secret that you can in fact see dead
people no I can't
yes you can no I can't
I'm quite positive that you can nope cut
hey hey what the hell it says in the
script that coal can see dead people I
can't see Debbie well I got to thinking
and the kids a liar Donny a straight-up
liar what'd ya think about it he's
wandering around telling people he can
see dead people but he can't see a damn
thing
why would he lie about that to make
Bruce Willis think he's nuts why would
he want to make Bruce Willis think he's
nuts because silly the kids in league
with the crazy mental dude at the
beginning of the movie really yeah so he
want he wants Haley Joel Osment to
finish what he started the ones Haley
Joel Osment to kill Bruce Willis yeah
but isn't Bruce Willis already dead yeah
he's so evil he wants to kill Willis
even after he's dead oh but ghosts have
rules right like you can't touch people
or get wet or do you eat after midnight
just like that movie aliens no et Oh
anyway he wants to convince Bruce Willis
that he's dead
yeah but I want to Ghostbusters in this
movie oh don't you get it Walter Peck
comes in and is like people people think
they're seeing ghosts arrest that man
cops get involved and they drop him off
at Ghostbusters headquarters okay and
Yvonne is like my PTA reading suggests
he's crazy and Jeanine is like oh my god
who would do such a thing
and Winston is like that creepy kid over
there and Bill Murray is like I'm Bill
Murray but what about the marshmallow
man I wanna watch him play the mental
patient that started a whole thing Brian
I know I already said the script of
Jacomo really what do you think oh he
loved it he's crying in the other room
right now I guess I moved him to tears I
like I like it a lot okay so they're
trying to get Bruce Willis he's trying
to kill Bruce was but how do you kill a
ghost that's already dead
okay well first of all you have to kill
yourself because the only thing that can
kill a ghost is another ghost right okay
look at me son yeah so uh mass suicide
and that's as far as I got but I mean
we're partners right we got work
together okay okay so so they I mean
just a met the ghost but everybody
commit to it so they can kill Bruce
that's the twist at the end is that
everyone's dead
ah maybe everyone's Tim Bruce Willis is
the only went a lot oh my god I love it
like the whole world blew up or
something yes as he's the only survivor
yes but how would he survive maybe he's
part conquerors Bruce Willis poor
cockroach he has kind of chakra yeah if
alien will bring et back in the whole
aliens you know after midnight yeah cuz
they turn into my Allegra exactly and
then he's the only one that lives and
then it will be Bruce Willis cockroach
fighting alien beings that look like
gremlins exactly and then a li Johnson's
there we're gonna do you can be gizmo
okay good I like this I mean - good work
partner good work partner we are awesome
yeah it was great already any impression
together other talents Oh Rexy mm-hmm
well I can do a bit of a Humphrey Bogart
kind of accent oh when you do crime you
do hard time go for moonshine a hard
time sure you don't want to do crime
you're he needs a little bit of
complicated situation don't do crime
because crime is bad good question and I
swear to god as eggsy in the scripts
apart can you do Bill Cosby beetle
girl's bed um once Gotham City is
destroyed you have my permission to
disappear that moved out
I do everything okay okay okay no a
voice actors show me how to do this
correctly once you do it you it's
addictive okay
it's a say you know you do your Sean
Connery you know cat voice you said if I
don't go like this you go like this like
it's awesome see um my Christopher
Walken accent is a little bit rusty
um I'm not sure if I want to really get
into it um mmm
Gideon Quito Heath Ledger Joker Oh way
I'm honestly never tried I may give it a
try just for him go nuts
um you want to know how I got these
scars
well you see I was little I loved
playing at playground and you know how
parents told you to never run with
scissors I sprinted with scissors
I just love just running them but they
weren't even normal scissors they were
safety scissors when I ran I ran into
the tree and I accidentally hit a rabbit
squirrel that's what jumped out the tree
and treated my face it was nuts
yeah hey I mean that's how it just would
take just a little amount of work but
that's pretty close from the first try
yeah yes we hydrogen ever try it yeah
that was good
any other a or towns or impressions
anything like that bone pickin up yet
are you familiar with salmon axe yeah oh
um mm I wish I had practices before I
have a demo reel and I swear I can do it
um how's it going Sam um hey really
going not kick some bad guy ass today
nah just let me get my chainsaw ready ah
it's more based off with a William cast
you know the time it shows you can do
now I actually Bret I played both the
reason I do and I would recognize
actually I the one that's close enough
yeah awesome cool let's go ahead and do
uh you are seen here then okay okay -
come on we need to talk about character
motivations now it's the sixth sense oh
it has to be pretty deep what do you got
well I was thinking the whole thing is
just a metaphor for the collective
unconscious you see Carl John thought
that we all had these archetypes and
inside of each of us as a sort of shadow
self so Bruce Willis is forced to
confront his shadow represented by the
mental patient he couldn't save and
Haley Joel Osment represents innocence
okay what about the action though
actually yeah you know fire explosion
that sort stuff um
um it's a ghost story um yeah
you can't put explosions in a ghost
story
no sure yeah ken did you see
ghostbusters they glowed the marshmallow
man Yugoslavian fashion model we're not
blowing up a marshmallow man okay okay
just you just Lobby a fashion model no
fine fine we'll compromise and just make
it a Yugo cars blow up easier anyway oh
we need to give a flattop oh and how do
you give a car a haircut that's not
important up yes it is
so you're onboard with the exploding car
great no oh all right marshmallow man
but that's my final offer
it doesn't make any sense the story is
about a dead man trying to save a little
boy's mind and a bunch of other people's
souls but mostly a creepy barking girl
it's not about she puffed candy you're
throwing your hot chocolate you're so
tight so obsessed with death
I won't go beyond them break the cycle
that isn't the only way we can do this
with a marshmallow man that's insane it
just like death see it all comes full
circle oh by the bike you need to make
the music fine you know what fine I
won't make the best damn musical ghost
story about kids who see dead people and
exploding marshmallows that money can
buy needless to say it'll be the best
damn worst thing on the planet aiming to
be the best I like that that's the
spirit logos you were there any
questions
where's the Tylenol oh and the Scotch
right next to it coincidentally but
before you go and do that though you
know I'm thinking I love your idea about
making it a musical and smart real smart
but what kind of songs are we gonna have
in this musical cuz I don't want it how
might people still take it seriously um
how about slaughter your world of by
performed by Mark Hamill Mark Hamill
doing the impression of his Joker Mark
Hamill as the Joker
singing slaughter your world mm how
would that work into the story
um it'll be a a semi romance a kind of
interpretation of his need to reach out
and try to get people to understand his
need to save the world from marshmallow
people so Bruce Willis when goes in song
form becomes Mark Hamill oh he meets up
with Mario well he need something he's
just marking oh no no no he he meets up
with Mark Hamill I mean that would be
really weird if he transformed into oh
so we have Bruce Willis and Haley Joel
Osment um I mean why not Mark Hamill
okay so he meets up with Mark Hamill and
they're gonna go sing a song called
slaughter your world yeah how we gonna
get Mark Hamill um we can just uh maybe
we didn't just get Bruce Willis to kinda
do this best impression of Mark Hamill
okay so I I do a version of Bruce Willis
doing Mark Hamill I like the whole
doughnut oh let's try to get Bruce
Willis I mean that's cute can you give
Bruce Willis oh I couldn't make a few
phone calls that's awesome to people
that can get Bruce Willis yeah hopefully
awesome awesome
okay now here's the big question would
all of this be inside Bruce builds his
mind almost like a psychological thing
like he's hallucinating or would it just
be real good make it psychological not I
like it real okay so the real stuff is
going on you know and I know what you're
going for you're thinking like now that
is but it's like Who Kicked vets in his
mind what interesting ever happens in
the mind but it's a sixth sense it's all
about if the home who is a metaphor
about what goes in on inside the mind
this will be perfect
Bruce Willis is just you know trippin on
all of this no it's real the marshal man
is real that Yugoslavian car is real and
it'll blow up it'll be unbelievable
you sir are an excellent writer this is
why I'm with you thank you thank you I
mean like what can I say
where's that scotch and the tile good
good good stuff you wanna stop things